this video is sponsored by one of my
personal favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation we
are back the trio is back for Echo
episode one today ladies and gentlemen
if you're watching this video maybe you
already watched all five what did you
think about the series John how are you
I'm excited cited cited Co he took my
joke joke joke joke I was going to do
the same same same same
same I can't
see that's the other one rule of Threes
baby leave a like on this video ladies
and gentlemen also be sure to subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
episode is up cuz we of course going to
cover the whole series thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights and a massive thank you to
all who have joined us at our patreon
page becoming super sexy rejects over
there we do full in action watch alongs
where you sync up with your own copy of
said movie or show we also covered
several things exclusive with highlights
from watch alongs included with this
being the first episode though of the
series it is made public for everyone
Link in the description box if you wish
to do a watch along let's get into
action
[Music]
Pap that's exciting for a Marvel show
we'll see challenge
accepted oh sweet hey it's like the Kori
T pool like I thought might relate and
everyone was like Co it's different
world and I was like I think multiversal
will play
here
wow look so
Cosmic
cool oh wa this is mature yeah bodies
silhouette damn that's beautiful it's
like
[Music]
annihilation
people of the hollow
Earth that's
cool so this is why she was able to
defeat
Hawkeye yes all of
this damn it what kind of bird is that
symbolism
oo oh damn just a bunch of colonizers
rolling in above them yes that was just
a giant flag being
planted o oh that's neat that's some
cool
makeup that's a really cool effect
shedding the clay of the earth almost
like being dusted but not
ah
yeah
whoa and we all have clothes the first
ch's name was
cha she saved her family from their
game Cool are they completely redoing
her origin that's the story of the first
shot people cool oh imagine yourself
through
there
no we're cousins no Exposition ran
straight into the uh Red River
[Laughter]
barash oh that the oh dad's
back I think you're
Peaches I don't know what the actresses
but these two actors I know and they're
great yeah I remember thinking the
casting for this was
stacked it'll be better in a few days
oh what are you feel like I'm missing
something at this bird you Quail scrub J
then why are you here I I don't know my
birds guys my research M of Theon
Society it's not a black cap Chickity
it's the only one I know cuz it was on a
clock I had
once
a no don't go in the storm that's where
things happen horrible
things something eating you I don't know
ancestors whispering in your ear again
goddamn ancestors why don't you asking
for something good like a bar
ball the ancestors are always playing
the
scratchers oh
no jeez
chiste that's the teest bone to ever
T-Bone so far I am appreciating how dark
and dtic this is and oh my
god oh that's how she lost her leg
[Music]
Yeah a that's
sad damn who did this score to
this
appreciate how cinematic it is the
actual Musical music itself yeah it's
more emotional than just like superhero
score I found out who cut the brakes
they're taken care of no who you think
that makes me feel better that another
family is now destroyed makes me feel
better wow I told her those Lopez boys
are no good thugs
criminals no nuh-uh you took her from us
you all right I think it's time to go no
it's time for him to go before someone
else gets hurt before someone buys a
tracksuit Henry got me a job where New
York isn't that far enough no wow leave
the country interesting how it started
off like so mystical and Fantastical
then it's become this like more and more
grounded focused family drama and
watching the grievance around the
supporting characters and not really so
much on Maya yet yeah her origin would
have to O
to it's actually a copyrighted
[Music]
image no that you did
not nah
man can't imagine having to tell a kid
that no it's not not a big deal yeah
Sunday I I do it as a side drob hobby
breaking tough news to
miners she's a veteran too no they got a
lot of actors who are great with solely
expression of Sorrow Through The
Eyes
I go too
[Music]
a man they shot all this on the volume
huh
y oh it's New
York wait isn't C Hawkeye yeah it's like
a flashback call
ask your uncle Danny Rand maybe they are
but dragons live in a different world
yeah sh
chos be season 3 that would make them
stronger you have to learn to jump
between two rooms like
kahori watch interesting how having this
scene in Hawkeye makes you think of it's
a completely different kind of context
yeah and he's in a track suit for
someone surviving as someone who is uh
hearing this is the Kingpin intro school
is your focus you're going to grow up
have a different life but then having
the mystical opening makes it a
completely different context yeah that
three minutes very different tone of
show uhoh
hey
bro at the dojo come on not at the Mojo
Dojo Casa house it's a sacred place the
Mojo Dojo Casa
house
may episode
one
ready jeez that look great edit love
that is this exactly what happened in
Hawkeye I wased in Hawkeye that one time
but I believe this is 100% the same
thing
[Music]
but as a fan of certain animes I like
going back to scenes like letting the
flashbacks really play out again because
like an expanded mythology you got to
taste and then it well yeah just like
the recontextualization of just seeing
it like this versus the first time you
watch it yeah we're so H lighter yeah
you view it in a completely different
lens even though you're watching the
same exact scenes it gives it further
Dimension but it does does make it the
shared Universe feel richer to have
Ronin and the pilot and to like expand
what we do know of
[Music]
her
ooh
Daddy
[Music]
O I still love that marking to get the
David maart like the the style of the
yeah the bloody
handprint oh there's still sister
cousins where's
Daredevil he's doing a walk of shame as
I watch She-Hulk I want to see Daredevil
when I watch Ekko I want to see
turle a here we
go
the how's she going to get out of
this she's going to do some Taskmaster
that's really cool I love the sound
design
TR damn that was actually a really cool
action
visual what's the point of that Maya
you're still trapped just a big big F
you just want to make a point if I can't
have this shiny red bike no one
C oh look at that music
[Music]
CU beat these guys head in the
door I like how the cops are just
terrified and back away we all mourn
your father I understand your
age my father was killed also a real
piece of work when I was 12 years old
Netflix is Canon let me help help you
release this rage in a more constructive
way let me take you to a rage room ad
job you have greatness in
you it is cool to see Vincent back
always your loss take your pain make it
into something
useful this is way more the Kingpin I
wanted back but you know V Kingpin is
pretty cool too Trader Joe's Kingpin
baby yeah restrain Kingpin is always
more terrifying than just flailing you
want it to like build and that was a
great scene of
him yeah whatever I love how New York
suddenly feels like kingpin's always
been here yeah that's how it should
really like should be in the shadows
it's entire yeah and that's what the
Daredevil show should be yeah we got
some more out of the
camera you're clear
up uh oh uh oh what's this guy gonna do
where they going to see she gonna have
to like lay this dude
out make those dudes turn around yep yep
yep she's cool so many channels now have
YouTube videos they can make when
standing up for themselves and things
that they definitely go through in a
day-to-day scenario but it's
woke they're trying to move in on FIS
territories we're going to take them out
let's try something else she'd be so
much prettier if she smiled more oh I
agree Oh you mean that
sarcastically yeah wait wait wait who
should I agree
with I do find it interesting that no
one's prepared for her deafness even
though kingpin's like a father Uncle
figure Kingpin thanks you for your loyal
he's got people he's busy who Jesu
christe oh it's a
Warner will it be in a hallway is this a
hallway get Dar EP I think we would get
dared I me based on the timeline it
would make sense like a daredevil right
now I got two more for the meeting what
no no it's cool bro they're expecting us
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah cool damn oh hell
yeah
got his
coffee oh oh that was sick the gunshots
man great camera
work Maya do
something oh yeah this is very violent I
like it a lot damn nice I love that she
gets brought in through a POV shot and a
perfect time for a hidden
cut the way they choose to go in and out
of her perspective via audio design is
really interesting and there's a slight
push every time right when it clicks
over oh yeah there was a crun oh
cool cool there was a CR I like that
focusing on the heartbeat to get the
emotionality and the calming back down
ex
exertion that's right
Maya G
that AES is always red that was
awesome yes death usage
just hey you
[Music]
again oh
damn are they using wires or did he just
jumped that
nice
that was
[Applause]
[Music]
legitimate here we go here we go here we
go oh no yo dude right yo damn it no you
guys could be a couple oh I love the
suit I've been watching them all night
and then you guys show
up I screwed everything up
oh this feels like
daril oh God a those blocks and stuff
great o the T great hold on the
[Music]
kick oo oh great seamless cut this is
excellent camera use the chain link
fence I think is also choice no Maya go
back to
she
Jesus no
guns The Matrix Arenal yeah very much
more John
wicking he is moving so well excellent
stunt
work and they keep pulling in on her one
foot too aw they cut it
yeah he's way faster than
that none of my men have ever held their
own with him like that you did better
than even I
expected it's like throwing Echo into
the Daredevil K immediately yeah what
you lacked was a place and a purpose you
have that now with me oh in my black
suit we're family no matter
what thank you Uncle
a this feels so much more Netflix than
the Disney Plus show how
so Hawkeye Stu Hawkeye stuff I've
dedicated all my resources into bringing
your father's killer to Justice this
feels like a Luke ban movie when you
find him he's
mine I wouldn't have it any other
way
Clint you count and I were the same
don't put Jeremy rener in the
snow it's okay he's back acting now it
could be used be manipulated your boss
wanted your father dead yes
your
boss you're lying wasn't a
typhoon
TJ's
Kingpin it's interesting seeing these
visuals from Hawkeye which felt a little
bit in conflict with the actual show
itself but they here because they were
the Netflix scenes in the plus and now
this is the show what a
surprise yeah like they play more
Sinister and menacing even though
they're the same scenes yeah father
family wonder if they change the sound
design too on these be interesting to
compare oh yeah definitely finished the
job because of the splicing there is
some weird Pace I'm enjoying it it's a
very doing a lot fast but but it's
pastes a little funny but one episod I
am really enjoyed it there's enough
working for me here though I think it's
really singing pretty high I feel like
the show's starting now but it's a very
it has a very luk based sound vibe to me
I thought it was going to be more
flashback spread throughout the season I
expected like Daredevil episode two and
to jump around they're really covering
their
bases where's your
suture or that or that works Terminator
is going to appear your clothes and your
boots I need
them there's a 53 on that truck there is
that an Easter egg I was thinking of
every issue that I really do I couldn't
think of
was all the blood on the
motorcycle going home to see
family oh that was a super clean cut I
love that cut good
match so far this has shot so uniquely
do not fall asleep on your
bike oh there's a also incredible in
camera stunt work top to bottom like has
there been any
I other than the very
[Music]
beginning just need to go play for a
little while don't we all yeah so busy
with the grind you forgotten how to play
and have fun the grind being murder
murder
crime how can you floss if you can't
hear
what do you listen to your
teeth got I hear
him that I heard that was a
crunchy
[Music]
yeah feels alien little bit feels like
Prometheus with the engineers yeah I
care more about her in the last 40
minutes minutes than I did in the whole
Hawkeye show they've done a really good
job reestablishing it's weird because I
care more about Hawkeye in the last 40
minutes and met Murdoch of course
but I mean it might just be the people
who live here whose home you no don't
shoot cousin no
there still might
be if my grandma finds out so much
squatting here there's going to be hell
to
pay
Maya it's me biscuits
biscuits hey
that's Billy Jack nice name he looks
like a Billy
Jack I've never been to Oklahoma but
these feel like people not from
California and I really like it they're
so calm they don't feel like actors I
wish I knew you were
coming for for a conference and and some
in and
out but what if Grandma sees you
sleeping on the couch it's a ghost
immediately like this guy well cast he's
got secret fighting skills he's got John
Vibes my is
[Music]
back everybody needs a foggy Nelson and
they got a good
one iron rings yes black crow there's so
many names I'm trying to
catch D there's a lot of really cool
like Center framing symmetry they do
with a lot of these shots and some cool
Focus lenses I wonder if this is a real
town or B or you know like a place with
a real level
of indigenous Heritage it's the volume
it's all the volume these people are the
volume oh yeah those are those AI extras
they keep telling me
about where's
Daredevil he's in the AM sneak pre the
next five episodes go pop out Bonnie B
Bonnie
Bonnie yeah Skate life Dam there are so
many tracks so many music tracks oh my
God I need a Saturn's ring disco ball
make a mar skate again oh it's not Kyle
gner he should get in the Marvel
Universe he
should I have a headache it's that guy
he's on agen of Shield you ain't from
here but you look familiar how
come mystery is your thing is
it guy's a combination with Evan Peters
and Boyd Holbrook yeah oh great call
Evan holbrook's doing good work this
dude's a good actor so it going to
be well if you ain't here to skate he
ain't available 7 bucks to skate or it's
five bucks to watch or you go ahead and
spend that $5 on a Butterfinger blizzard
five bucks to watch Voyer skate Evan
Holbrook is really good at playing like
detached sociopathic characters so I'm
curious as to who this guy turns out to
be yeah I worry for his safety
[Music]
inevitably we knew we couldn't trust you
Evan Holbrook damn you dude the king
killer king killer this information made
it all the way to Oklahoma probably
because they were like criminal
underbelly really it reached didn't it
like that that team of people oh yeah
yeah yeah I mean her her papy had
going on out here took it out there so
he's all right the pain in my ass but
he's worked for me a painus in the anus
so they finally caught up to you oh it's
like her dad's to
two bullet or blade
all right are we working with
here what a
cut I'm a big fan of the transition
keeps the Cana from slipping out of your
karate during the sanguin but uh I don't
think we're bombing you
today always a good
[Laughter]
day
a full this guy moves I like the accent
of his speech with like I love how he
talks oh T nice take a deep breath that
looks
infected uhoh she's safe is she with
this telescope up here if she finds out
you were here and you didn't see her
you will break her
heart your sisters yeah there is a
firmness in the way he
talks Fisk that's an Easter egg that's
why they know yes but but to what what
does that mean Feast Fe oh they spelled
fist wrong all right we got to explain
the ending video coming up I figured you
needed more for me than stitches here's
10 guns how far is Oklahoma from New
[Music]
York I won't bring a war here to the
people I love oh why are you doing
this
uhhuh oh green pitten crime Mommy does
she become the queen of crime no I mean
she ends up bring a daredevil quite a
bit
dude man her drips too that fishnet Le
jacket combo no there there's an element
of like is she working for her own needs
when helping Daredevil out and that
that's something I think they could do I
don't know how far they'll go
though look at that
Countryside at the end of the episode oh
was King wake it up he I was like I hope
not actually
nice oh it does it does move in like
those grungier like the Daredevil movie
from the 2000s mes it's moving quick
that moves in that kind of like
aggressive dark fastpac it could have
been six episodes and breathed a
[Music]
little oh look at that like that that
gritty oh whoa whoa whoa whoa we don't
even watch a preview no we got them all
day and date yeah man gosh coming soon
on 5 minutes don't click off this
episode watch the next one thank you to
Rocket money for sponsoring this video a
brand that I am happy to be partnered
with thrilled to it's fortunately one
that I have been using for quite a while
now prior to ever green to a partnership
with them I was like that makes for the
best kind of synergy promotion because I
can actually talk about them from my
heart here reason being like many of you
guys U like for years I am constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps
that I keep forgetting to use or I don't
really find quite as beneficial rocket
money has been the one the only one I'm
not just saying it is the only one that
I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game
Cher for me on a very personal note
running real rejects is an absolute
privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning
of the year and I'm like I'm trying to
be smarter and get it all done now I
already started like a a couple months
ago getting things in order managing
real reject finances while managing my
own personal finances has been an
ongoing struggle and I'm very big on
like efficiency and being organized but
clearly wasn't as good enough as I uh
thought I had so before rocket money
came into my life I was drowning in
subscriptions and struggling to keep
track of my expenses and as I really
wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for
me I was overwhelmed with subscriptions
I didn't even know I had or had still
been subscribed to I mean do you ever
wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the
time to really do it it could be a
little daunting rocket money helped me
see what I was missing and best part
they even canceled those subscriptions
for me with just a simple tap so with
rocket money you can have all your
subscriptions in one place making it
easy to cancel anything unnecessary
without the hassle of dealing with
customer service my is so annoying plus
they'll work on getting you refunds and
negotiate lower bills saving you up to
20% you just snap a pick of your bill
and let Rocky money take care of the
rest let me just summarize for you
really quick what they are they're a
personal finance app that fines and
cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors
your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500
million in cancel subscriptions they've
already saved members an average of $720
a year they help save me a little bit
more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions
cancel them today at Rocket money.com
rejects that's rocket money.com rejects
if you've heard other people talk about
them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and
yes using them is also a great way to
support the channel same time it's just
a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me
take control of your finances with
rocket money and enjoy financial peace
of mind uh let's talk about episode one
even though you guys like just watch
episode two there's there's four more
now no we don't roll that way talk this
for 40 minutes talk about 40 more
minutes no we can just keep it short uh
right now I mean because it is a bin
show I don't feel it's proper to like I
I've adjusted to the way times have
changed that we should just kind of
watch the rest before obviously before
making a final assessment in terms of a
pilot episode I think it was really good
it's a good strong start um I do I am
kind of craving a bit of a change of
specific pacing I understand that we
have to get a lot of setup out of the
way uh you know you're also got to tie
it into like yeah how does it connect to
the Hawkeye stuff cuz you were cutting
prior to the Hawkeye events interweaving
into the Hawkeye events and then now we
got to go post the Hawkeye events so
you're essentially doing better call Sol
but in one episode and uh so far though
I mean for positives for me I really
love uh the the composition of the shots
I think there's a lot of this really
intriguing symmetry they have with all
their angles I think like the big talk
of this will probably be the Daredevil
fight be and I which I actually really
respected the handling of that because
they first get you invested into the
action scene before Daredevil ever
shows homeboy could learn to hide a yawn
a lot better John was I don't know what
you're talking about so powerful that
was so good what AE I didn't even open
my mouth you can't prove that I ever did
anything with my
breath I was just shocked soad your I'm
just shocked by how good your point was
I was like
a TI to but if there's a Tik Tok clip
out from this episode it's that moment
that Wasing you cannot mask any worse
than that you know you just open your
mouth and I start fall taking a big old
gas watching this show at are we
watching this at like 11: in the morning
what's happening right now never
know keep ja up anyway the segue into
the
the segue into that was getting you
invested into the action and the visual
like literally a sensory experience and
and and Hawkeye and uh Hawkeye and Echo
fighting first and then Daredevil shows
up yes prior to let's get invested in
Daredevil first being here and and so it
was smart for the placement of it and
this like really smart way of how
they're kind of separating itself from
the voice of Hawkeye and then now
putting her in the voice of the Netflix
Daredevil shows yeah it's like mainly
there but like those shows were paced
better but granted this is sort of a
reintroduction so I'm waiting to see how
this all plays out but loving the
casting and uh so far I I really enjoyed
the first episode uh I think action
looks and um Maya Lopez uh the who's the
actress John you would knowa Cox is her
name I would know and John delivered and
yeah I think what I'm waiting for on
there it it's a tall it's a it's a tall
order to ask because you it's all going
to be Reliant primarily on body language
and expression to get really invested
into her and I like the choices of like
how they will use uh sound design to
kind of get you into what's going on
internally with her Beyond just speaking
sign language and just Expressions that
she has like it's kind of a neat way to
get you into her perspective and her
heart uh which I thought was really
smart uh but I I am still going all
right well it is her show still and I'm
going to need to really get invested in
her like her but you know it's still a
journey so so first episode those are my
quick three minute thoughts who wants to
go next who wants to go next oh oh pick
me pick me pick me pick me teacher uh I
I like this a lot and I agree with most
of what you said so I'm not going to you
know ramble I have one main concern
which is kind of interesting I'm I'm I'm
curious to see how this will play out
across five episodes
because in one breath the pace of this
episode I thought they made it work it
moves real fast it's splicing in a bunch
of stuff from the past and it could have
felt like it was edited in a blender and
I didn't feel like that however I feel
like when you're in the newer scenes in
the past where you're dealing with her
family and stuff like that the way this
episode is paced made me worry for
future episodes basically not taking
much time for that like when they're on
top of the big uh Tower thing and
they're looking down on Bonnie like that
was like a scene between those two
characters and you got the sense for you
know their kind of back and forth
Rapport and like that was not the most
breathable scene but it was a breathable
scene and I liked that flavor and I
think if you really want to sell us on
all the stuff that they're doing I just
hope that they will take the time
appropriately much like the Daredevil
Show on Netflix would have done to yeah
just uh appropriately Revel in these
character beats so that we care that
much more but like I said from here I
already cared more about Maya and her
various relationships and her journey
thus far more than in Hawkeye and I like
dur Hawkeye I thought she was a cool
addition but it was sort of like this
other thing happening on the side of
that show so yeah like this had all the
punch and all the mood and all the
atmosphere and all the look that you
want and now I just hope that it it
breathes a little bit feel like not that
it's a great onetoone comparison but
like Z mandan's on uh he's great on
reservation dogs and that show really
lets you live in what this town looks
like it could be which is like you know
a strong populated indigenous sort of
area or town not that this is
necessarily on a reservation but you
know like that stuff I feel like that's
part of what you want to steep yourself
in when you're getting to know this
person's story and especially with these
teases of you know the birth of the
chock top people and this this fantasy
you know I hope they can proportionately
balance all that stuff out because I
like that you have this Prospect of
something Cosmic and something you know
mystical at the beginning which is
appropriate for folklore and that side
of things and it doesn't Clash too hard
or contrast too you know dissonantly
with you know the gritty rough and
tumble like super tangible very real
kind of style they're going with so I'm
I'm curious to see how they blend those
moving forward but uh strong start by my
metric yeah yeah I like it more than
iron fist season one uh and that's clear
that bar that all right all right Coy
now keep in mind we also did not talk
about Kingpin nope we didn't about two
so to me this feels like the Marvel
Knights imprint of comic books which I'm
hoping is what they do with the search
light obviously uh I think sorry
Spotlight I think Spotlight is going to
be more Spotlight Spotlight I apologize
Spotlight is going to be more than just
dark characters I assume it's going to
be able to highlight other characters
and uh you know it is it is distracting
I immediately felt Greg's tired guys but
the spotlight I don't think is just
going to be dark characters but I do
think like Marvel lights Marvel Knights
it does allow you to have an imprint
have a different feel and the feel of
Kingpin doesn't quite fully feel like
Netflix to me but it definitely feels
closer to Netflix than Hawkeye and I
feel like you have a really unique
opportunity here to have characters like
Ekko like Daredevil like Ghost Rider
like blade you have these characters
that belong in the dark and I would love
if they take more opportunities for
things like this my biggest concern is
that it is five episodes it is getting
kind of dropped unceremoniously quickly
uh I hope that with Hulu airing it it
will get a little bit more Prestige
because Hulu does have really good
content that is darker I'm hoping an
audience that loves that stuff finds
this and it kind of brings them into the
fold and that it gets enough numbers to
show that audiences want this darker
content uh I do think that the Kingpin
was able to retroactively make those
scenes in Hawkeye work I do think that
Vincent and arreo is incredible when
he's like this you know the little like
cars you pull back and you wait to
launch them I always feel like Kingpin
is the car like right here I feel like
kingpin's always like pois and I think
my issue with Hawkeye was we spent three
years of of like him like this with
occasional lashing out and launching and
Hawkeye was just like it was like a Hot
Wheel I don't want a Hot Wheel I want a
poised Viper and I really feel like here
we got the Viper and I want more of that
pacing that I do worry that with a a
five episode run it will have to be so
feverish but I really enjoyed this more
than I expected um two Parallels for me
that I didn't expect to jump into my
mind I really enjoy Dominique Thorne in
wakanda forever because I love iron
heart and I think she's a good iron
heart but I did feel like that scene
some of those scenes at times felt like
they they got added I think they always
intended to use her she did screen test
with Chad Boseman before we lost him but
it felt like they added a couple more
scenes in order to be like we got a
series coming I felt similarly towards
the character in Hawkeye where I imagine
she was always going be in it but I
think once they decided to make a
spin-off there was more and I I felt
like it was a detriment to both things
Hawkeye felt like it was trying to do
too much and it didn't feel focused and
then I also felt like I didn't connect
to her I feel so connected to her
because of how they introduced Daredevil
back in because they made us familiar
because they had their own and scene but
I'm afraid unless they give us some time
with just her it will feel like they're
doing too much and then the other thing
it reminded me of is do you remember the
scenes in the Weeden cut that were
Snider and it was like what's happening
and then it go back to then this that
that different tone just felt odd I
thought this did a really good job of
kind of like the SN cut keeping its
truth and integrity while incorporating
other elements and making you remind you
what you like about the Netflix shows
and what you like about those things so
this reminded me of like okay don't let
Hawkeye distract you because that wasn't
my cup of tea I liked parts of it but it
did feel like I was doing too much this
feels like more that streamline I have a
vision I have a tone this felt like
directed this felt like edited felt like
it was dpd it felt like a a a property
not like a product and at times Hawkeye
felt like a product so I really enjoyed
that this feels like there's artistic
Merit and there's a lens that someone
shooting it through that sees a vision
yeah I would I would definitely no all
puns intended I would 100% Echo
that I've have one wait because sorry I
thought you were going to wrap up the
video did you th% what just happened I
thought you were heading the wrap up
start making a point and he just goes I
uh I want to you had that posture of
Greg's about to I was I was just I was
transitioning enjoying pool so much dud
I'm just going to go I already forgot my
point John what were you going to say I
literally forgot my point so the vibe
literally forgot my point this early
January for days what what are you going
to say no you were going to say
something about
Kingpin I said
SN
SN say what point you were going to say
how does Kingpin know zero sign language
that's one thing thing that I did not
get about this that I feel like would be
important for how important he is to her
existence and their bond and everything
he's got this freaking translator who
we've never seen before who I guess is
around just all the time and then none
of the other people are prepared for
this high ranking person in his
organization to speak sign language
either no his sign language clearly is
not I want to say I'm I'm glad you
interrupted me for this uh that his sign
language is this is my favorite
language is he no in Hawk they have a
scene here when he before he gets shot
like when he speaks he's clearly
amateurish at it he only knows a few
words but how has he known her so long
he's been her uncle since she was a
child he's never b a secret Epstein
billionaire he's been able to like
heated
guy on the flight logs for sure I I I
agree I do age I could also see the flip
where he probably just always had a
translator with it I don't have time to
learn this I got to go kill people and I
didn't ever look at my translator once
across all the repeat words I must have
said and have said to me he picked up
seven to nine words we saw that's enough
for 20 odd
years oh but yeah I I really liked it
more than I expected to be honest yeah
yeah it's good I I really can't remember
what I was I it would come back to I
trying for a second I was
like I really can't recall artistic
Vision a specific lens a creative idea
from top to bottom SN cut uh what else I
talk about Netflix I I Echo that so
maybe I don't know yeah like it it
doesn't feel like yeah no it doesn't
feel like the Disney Plus shows it
actually it actually feels like they let
the filmmakers make film which is pretty
cool to
see I saw that breath come
up this whole season I'm just going to
watch body language and see how this
I got this go I'm ready to go all righty
all righty guys well I'm done um I'm
finished been in a Daniel de Lewis mood
lately moans no and I love Michael man
yeah I have I've been wanting oh you
haven't seen it either no we should do a
three-way
reaction uh yeah that's Michael man
right dramatic yeah the three of us
should sit for 3 hours and watch I
really I really want to watch
watch Offa watch New Year's Day I
watched this like documentary about like
one of those like 40 minute videos about
D le Lewis and and uh like I haven't
seen last of them moans I'm a huge
Michael Man Fan I'm more Michael Man Fan
than Daniel de Lewis I love Daniel de
Lewis but I think Michael man's in my
top 10 directors and I think that's the
only film of his I haven't seen I
watched Ferrari it was okay yeah it's
spich man though yeah I love Miami Vice
though nobody loves Miami Vice there so
much like space Patrick Williams loves
Miami Vice got to love a good mojito
I couldn't even finish it oh really
seen did not like it Char's mustache is
like two mustaches in that movie anyway
uh yeah oh and the other thing too is
um ex what I liked so far about like I
don't know you know what honestly help
me out here guys people in the comments
help my uneducated mind who tries to
sound politically
correct say the right things that are
respectful uh when it comes to the Chaka
Nation uh being inclusive in here and I
don't know what nation or tribes or like
what the specific race of the actors
that they got involved in this project
are uh what I say what I really
respected about it like they start off
on this mystical element which is neat
to see however when you are just in the
present day they're not having all these
conversations which I'm sure they will
have when exploring the culture you're
just with the people you're just with
the characters and to me that's usually
my favorite kind of representation is
when you just have the actors and the
characters there and then eventually
have some of more of these like
conversations you know and so far right
now with that Premiere episode I thought
was a really interesting way to do it
because I don't know what all this
mystical stuff I feel like I don't know
if that's going to be inter dispersed
and then build right I think it maybe
it's inspired by like actual culture
stuff but there's a lot of fictional
things that they're probably including
in there as opposed to they are adapting
some very specific you know um Faith or
playing with North Norse mythology like
it's a it's an augmented play on a yeah
that's what I imagine they're doing I
but I don't know I really I really don't
know I have no knowledge so uh maybe is
this real mythology is this the real
creation myth yeah uh it's this real
like choon Nation um the faith folklore
and faith folklor is the word I'm
looking for
spirituality all righty guys well um uh
I don't know if I ever found that point
but I'm happy to be here anyway it
doesn't matter we're at the end of the
video all right well thanks for being
here and uh let's watch episode two
episode two let's do
it guo Galindo welcome to your second
month of shout outs here for real
rejects now it's 2024 start of a new
year I'm going to Fathom what your New
Year's resolution is oh and your New
Year's resolution this year is to clip
your nails a little more often I know
you you're Italian those things get
really long and disgusting and full of
spaghetti sauce I understand how it goes
man that's a the ball plumbing and
you're it gets icky and you don't wash
your hands and then your nails get all
dirt dirty and you're like ah forget
about it then you give a backand to your
spouse I get it man I know how it goes
somebody some concrete shoes get it all
over your hands yeah you know and then
you have them swim with the fishes ah
forget about it so uh guo Galindo man I
hope that you know cleaning your
fingernails it's a great way to make
sure you're not leaving you know uh
evidence
behind and also you won't pick up any
blood residue from all the dead bodies
that you're hauling around and digging
up shovel for I get how it goes let's
just make sure my racist shout out is
accurate
gindo is name origin hold on a second
Spanish oh my bad oh no okay well then I
hope you're
colonizing um yes I hope you're sending
some conquistadors our way when you're
colonizing my friend um you know you can
get a lot of dirt in your hands when
you're taking over land that's true and
blood and all sorts of other things
making sure you
can make sure you can effectively take
the things that are are mandated as
yours that you truly right fully deserve
yeah yeah we got this under control
so G I hope this has encouraged you to
stick through for the remainder of the
year because clearly we care about TLC
and customization when shouting people
loud happy New Year clip your nails they
look
[Music]
gross